Today, we're going
to be learning
how to recycle some pallets
into a decorative wall
and some floating shelves.
[Music]
Guys, there's a good chance
that in the past,
you've seen some interesting
projects done with the wood
from shipping pallets.
These things are everywhere.
Pretty much anything
that's getting shipped
in large quantities gets shipped
on one of these pallets
because they're cheap to make,
and they're very sturdy,
and they're designed
in such a way
that a forklift can manipulate
them really easily.
We are in the middle
of redecorating our studio.
We've got some paint up,
we're in the middle
of a couple projects,
and now, our next step is
to redo this wall over here.
This wall doesn't show up
in our videos a whole lot
in the past.
We're hoping it will do
so more in the future
because we're going to try
and make it a
little more photogenic,
instead of just being
a pale, off-white,
tannish colored wall,
it's going to be a wall made
out of pallet wood,
which has a lot of character,
and looks really good
in my opinion.
So, we got our hands
on a bunch of these pallets.
We're going to be
doing two things:
one is covering a big portion
of the wall in the pallet wood.
But we also need
a good place to display
our YouTube Play Buttons.
So we're going
to make some shelves,
and not just shelves
with obvious visible support,
we're going to make
what's called floating shelves.
Those are shelves
where you can't really see
how it's attached to the wall
because it looks like just a box
stuck right on to the side.
We're going to show you
how we're building those,
we're going to attach it all,
and then we're going
to cover that whole wall
with pallet wood.
Here's the basic idea.
It only takes a few tools
to turn old pallets
into usable wood.
We're going to be using
that wood to refurbish one
of the walls in our workshop,
and make some shelves
for our YouTube Play Buttons.
First up, let's take a look
at how we've prepped the wall
before we put anything on it.
So here's the wall.
It used to be
sort of tan-colored,
now, it's black,
and that's what I mean
by prepping the wall.
We've painted the
whole wall black.
We filled in a couple of spots.
There were some bullet wounds.
They're not completely gone.
But since we're going
to be covering this whole thing
in the pallet wood,
it doesn't need
to be a 100% perfect.
We like the black
because pallet boards
are not perfect.
They don't fit 100% together,
unless you're going to run
everything through a planer
and a joiner,
and make it all
just finely machined,
and we're not doing that.
We like the rustic look.
So this way,
when there's tiny little gaps
in the boardms or holes
or knots or something like that
and we can see through,
it just looks dark.
You won't see the light colored
wall like shining through it.
So we've gone ahead,
used a fairly matte black,
covered the whole wall,
and it's ready to go.
The first thing we need
to do is to get all
of the planks off our palates,
and these planks,
these flat thin ones,
that's what we're going for.
And you can try
and pull them all off,
but if you do that with a hammer,
you're likely to start
splitting the wood.
The nails don't always
like to pull out.
So I actually think
the best way to do it is to just
cut right down through them.
I got a reciprocating saw
with a metal blade on it,
and it should make pretty
quick work of the nails.
[Music]
I've now cut down both sides,
the left and the right,
and so they're just
connected in the middles.
So now I can do one
at a time with those.
If while you're cutting,
you realize that the board
is just really pressed up
against too hard
to fit the blade in,
you can usually just grab it
and start wiggling it,
and that'll pull it
away a little bit,
enough to fit
the blade in better.
[Music]
We've got our YouTube
Play Buttons here,
and we're going to display
them in this order:
the Silver, the Gold,
and the Diamond.
The Gold is the biggest
and heaviest to display.
The Diamond currently
doesn't have a display case,
but we're probably going to go
ahead and build one of these.
It's going to be a box
fairly similar to this.
It won't be as large
as the gold one.
And so, we're just gonna have
some floating shelves,
one for each these.
It's going to be just
a little bit wider
than each of these boxes,
should be nice and supported
in studs in the wall.
This one is
actually quite heavy.
So we need a very sturdy shelf
that can hold that up.
We may try and attach it to
the wall a little bit as well,
just to make sure it's
really in there nicely.
Here's the idea.
We are going to start off
with this 2x3 board.
A piece of this is going to
get bolted right into the wall.
We're going to use
some very strong screws,
going in some studs,
that should give us all
the support we need.
It will not be this long.
This is going to be cut shorter.
We're then going to use
some pallet boards,
and build a box
that fits right
around this 2x3 board.
So we'll have a piece there,
and a piece there.
We're gonna use a table
saw to cut these down
so it all fits,
and it is just
the exact right size.
We'll measure all of this,
will take this 2x3 out.
These three pieces
will be attached together
after they're cut to being
just the right size.
Then, this board, the 2x3,
will get mounted to the wall,
and then we'll fit
this sort of box
that we've built over the 2x3,
and attach it from
the top and bottom
so it's secured well.
[Music]
Now, we're gonna use a jigsaw,
and just cut right along the
pencil line that we've drawn in.
[Music]
I like the depth of this one.
This one's a little too big.
So we're going to trim this down
so it matches this one.
[Music]
These two boards do stick out
from the wall farther
than this piece.
So we're just going
to add a few supports
to give a little bit
of extra strength.
[Music]
Excellent.
Here we go.
This will mount right here,
got studs in the wall
here and here,
and have screws right there
and right there.
You know what?
Just to be extra sure,
I think we're going to put two
more right here and right here
with wall anchors.
[Music]
I've got these two holes
drilled into drywall,
and there's no stud
behind that part.
This part is going
to be nice and strong,
this parts is not as strong.
So we've got these wall anchors.
They fit down
inside the plaster.
And when a screw goes
inside the plastic,
it actually splits the plastic
apart and deforms it,
making it grip into
the plaster wall a lot stronger.
So each of these is rated
up to 15 pounds of strength.
Two of them should give me 30,
then added that into
the strength of the screws
that are going to the studs,
this should be able to hold
the weight, no problem.
We've got these two
screws lined right up
with those in the wall.
[Music]
Lovely.
Now, we're just going to use
two fairly small screws
in through the bottom,
attaching this whole box
onto the support
that's in the wall.
That should hold it in place.
All of the weight
gets distributed into the shelf,
which is nice and strong,
and it's really hard to see
how it's being held up.
That's what makes
it a floating shelf.
Now, to be honest,
even though we've got
this cool shelf,
we are going to add
a little bit of reinforcement
in the form of hooks
that attach to these things.
Because while I am confident
that the shelf
can take the weight,
this is a little bit top-heavy,
so if anything bumped it,
it could fall off forward.
So, not so much to hold it up.
As to hold it back,
we are going to
have hooks attached.
Once we've got
the whole pallet wall up,
we'll attach a couple of those,
and that will stop
it from ever...
diving off.
With our shelves in place,
it's time to actually start
putting in the pallet boards
all the way over this wall.
This is actually pretty easy.
We've got a nail gun
with 18 gauge finishing nails.
We're just going to be using
those right into the boards.
We place these in a row.
We're going to do a full row
of boards all the way across.
Before we start going up at all.
That way, we can make sure
that the entire row is
the same width of board.
That's gonna make it
a lot easier to get everything
to fit together nicely.
[Music]
Guys, our wall is complete.
It's looking great.
We got the whole pallet
wall all built up.
We've got the floating shelves.
We've got the YouTube Play
Buttons on the shelves.
I'm loving how this is looking.
It turned out super good,
and it's going to be really nice
to have this sort of contrast
to the look of everything
else we've got in the studio.
Pallet walls is a pretty easy
and fast to build,
relative to a lot
of other things.
There are some things
you should know.
You probably don't want
to put them in like
any kids bedrooms or stuff.
So, this is a workshop.
Not a lot of reckless kids
going to be down here
trying to climb on the walls
and licking stuff.
So, it's a good place
in my opinion for a pallet wall,
and I'm really happy
with how this turned out.
This has been
a super fun project,
and I'm so glad you got
to watch this with us.
If you do end up making
any of these shelves,
or especially the pallet wall,
we want to see it.
So take pictures,
and tag us on Instagram
and Twitter @TheKingofRandom.
Guys, that's not all.
We've always got more
for you to see.
This box up at the top
is going to take you directly
to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box shows you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And you've got this bomb
here in the middle.
You hit that, you'll be
subscribed to the channel,
and that way, you're never going
to miss out on a cool video.
Don't forget to ring the bell
so you always get
notified about it,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.